able to beat arslan ash to make it into
the top eight he then beat a west honey
then ashari then dark prince and now
he's going up against tk bilal
mala nasser bilal
the lcq champion of 2019 in thailand
and all around one of the best players
or best brian's in the world here we go
first it's reaction fight
here we go oh my gosh out the gates
throwing it out there making it count
you better not tech roll you better not
okay oh
yeah it's very important for bilal to
compose himself after the loss he took
in the winner's side you know it was
very very uh dominant so
he needs to get that confidence back
slowly slowly build up his confidence by
winning these rounds
oh my god the second time he would go
for
her again
but he was ready locked and loaded with
the hotkey that's the second sequence
we've seen in this opening round where
he goes for a time but was made with a
hot kick
nice
and talking to bella he says that the
dow ford one is his favorite move with
brian confirmable man a lot of damage
yeah i mean his use of that gatling rush
series is so good because you know it it
really forces the opponent to kind of
pay attention to when you're gonna stop
if you're gonna continue
and you could go for the cheeky cheeky
delay
yes
oh
this is going to hurt it's going to
count at the wall as well no just short
of it
now what oh my god oh come on
what's that situation
it's gonna do a ton of damage it's not
gonna kill
but we're gonna be one step closer
what's the mix of standing three
no he goes
bro he put the pressure on in two rounds
straight for below but it could have
gone either way
yeah
okay
lies damn to hit magic four hey hey
oh my god he's changing them down he is
trying to make oh no jets that's what
bella is doing
he wants to make you happy all right
yeah man a man after my heart
yo that was pretty damn dominant if you
ask me
that was pretty good
it was pretty good i think that's the
best way that you want to answer back
after losing the way you did in that
winner's side so he has momentum now and
below with momentum is a hard allowed to
stop man so uh let's see what fgl can do
to answer back but it is first of threes
they have more time to work with we
haven't really seen him do too badly at
all versus anyone with that lily like we
have now this is the first time that you
know fgl will be fighting that adversity
um and we haven't seen if you played any
other characters it is first of three uh
so
uh let's see what he can do here i don't
we haven't seen him play any other
character today but you know it wouldn't
surprise me if he had one you know in
the pocket just for a rainy day
i mean what if what if lily's not even
his best character who knows who knows
who knows yeah it's always fun for oh it
was fun uh in a good time for surprises
but either way
seeing lily being played this well
already has been such a surprise beating
some of the top players from around the
world you know very known players so he
has to be happy about how he's done in
the tournament so far
yeah and it's about being you know so
some people are different some people
will be like you know i'm happy with the
performance that i have anything else is
an extra it's a bonus let me just play
as uh the best that i can and let's see
what happens right this is the exact
same attitude that bella had in the lcq
where he got top 32 he's like i'm happy
with top 32. i got i didn't drown him
falls let me just play my game and
whatever happens happens and he managed
to win the entire thing fgl maybe he's
not a situation as well maybe he
actually wants to win the entire thing
he's like you know what i beat arslan i
beat a waste i beat asharif i do not
want to lose this tournament now after i
took out those guys you know you know i
don't want to do all that hard work and
just lose it at the end you know so uh
the pressure is on either way uh first
to three action so
looking good
poised to make it back into that grand
finals versus khan where you know he
needs to get that out of his head you
know he has a tough ass in front of him
here with fgl can he um
can he get back into that grand finals
uh and and do
what he was able to do
at the lcq he knows he can do it but
it's going to be tough
i'm pretty confident i mean the way he
kind of handled that first match right i
feel like he
has to be feeling good about the matchup
the confidence going into it however you
know if you look at just what we saw
those rounds were close they were not
one-sided by any means those rounds were
definitely close it looks like why do
you was definitely prepared he knew
certain options like hey you're not
gonna get a free taunt in my face right
i'm not just gonna stand there and block
i know when you have openings and i'm
gonna go for it uh case in point you
know there was this one situation where
he kind of pushed his way in and boom
matterhorn cannon launched him into the
sky so he definitely has a read on
timing and mix-ups and just much like
what we saw in the akuma matchup he was
definitely prepared however it was three
rounds straight for below so he has to
be feeling good he's up 1-0 right now
again this race to three so two more
matches for below he'll be able to go
back into grand finals uh ygl
we've seen him down before he can make a
comeback
yeah for sure man and again just want to
stress that it's a point that i
i was thinking about yesterday that this
this this these couple years that we've
had of online have really allowed
certain players to make a name for
themselves which we have which we never
would have seen had this situation not
come so sometimes you got to take the
positives and everything even when
there's negatives you know you've got to
take you got to sometimes take the
positives out of it and one of the
positives being that there's so many
players around the world in every region
america us uh in in the eu in pakistan
asia everywhere where people have been
able to perform online and make a name
for themselves even in a in a country in
a region as strong as pakistan
you know players like dark prince and
like um fgr have been able to make a
name for themselves using the online
where maybe now they'll be able to go
offline and and they'll be known they'll
be like oh that's the guy that came top
three in the tekken online challenge you
know we had the same situation in um
in in europe last year with tlc as well
and even this year with with with um
players that were not well known or
offline that did really well online in
these in these uh exhibitions once again
shout outs to banana entertainment astro
and all of the sponsors uh that allowed
this to happen because uh without this
there's um you know i the
tech community would be a lot smaller
that's for sure
of course we are waiting for the players
to get back in
and uh us able to continue the event so
again thanks everyone for your patience
sometimes these things take time so
uh i know you guys may be used to like
rapid fire matches back to back to back
but uh the reality is you just think
about it these guys are sitting at home
they're waiting they're walking around
they're pacing they're hitting their
buttons like oops i messed up we did a
button check again oops
three more times mark man is pissed this
bag is laughing at mark man
yeah like i feel like they did that on
purpose
it's just they do things differently man
you know what i'm saying they do things
differently so in in pakistan and i i'm
i'm really uh happy that i was able to
be um one of the guys that helped these
guys to transition into the into the
into the tekken esports world you know
um like because things would in pakistan
are done so differently um that you know
they needed a bit of help to like get
involved even when it comes to uh
even when it comes to uh like streaming
on twitch and all these things you know
they needed help to have someone to just
you know get them started with that
stuff and they've been putting in a lot
of content mark i don't know if you've
been seeing but like my old dark prince
so many of these guys are that computer
today even islam and these guys they all
have youtube channels bilal too they all
uh constantly post videos of their sets
and and analysis videos and everything
they're really on it with the content so
shout out to all of the scene in
pakistan and they're doing a really
really good job uh but yes we're getting
into our second match now is it going to
be the lily still yes and we're going to
a infinite stage now mark
it's the classic i mean you know
characters with superior movement
ability
tend to
like going to the open stage especially
if they feel like they're restricted
anyways uh that's a good good
opportunity you know pick the open stage
let's see how it works out but again
you got to make sure it counts otherwise
you're going to be down 2-0 right now
fgl
fighting here both of these players in
the losers bracket the law up 1-0
oh man he is testing his opponent
not only with the delay gatling rush
he's using the four four three four
waiting for him he was already ducking
he was ready locked and loaded
okay
oh oh
okay
now that is actually seeable like a lot
of people say that is a seal below um
good thing that bilal low cried that
because that'll make fgl think twice
about throwing that one out
oh yo
the wheel king
let's go yeah fight
below desperately wants to get back into
that grand finals look at that
i'll tell you what man brian does a lot
of power major oh my gosh
he wants a speed one right now he's
speed
running he's going for a pb he's on a
world record pace though
see what he does
oh the second hit he wasn't ready
catch him one for the low jab oh wow
what the [ __ ]
nice
he's in trouble it's not gonna kill but
he's in trouble
what no way
sometimes just things don't go away but
man that was a such an unfortunate round
loss there what happened
oh no and when you win rounds like that
that you shouldn't have won it gives you
so much momentum right now fgl
opportunity to go up but below a lovely
sidewalk and punish
there's only one way to steal that
momentum back
there's only one way to do it you have
to
let him know you have to disrespect him
you know what i'm talking about
yeah
where's the top
where's the uppers oh my god
yo fgl is fighting back he's trying to
he's trying to get it he's trying to get
it off
he's clutching out so many of these
rounds back turn one plus two full
launch fgl with the momentum
no he messed up the follow up
and no launch on the power crush no jet
upper
not good
no punish on the knee
let's see what happens
both these players trying to use their
movement here trying to find
an opening
oh nice threading the needle
pressure is on rage available
plus flames
now
wow
final round very important round here
for both of these players the law's
either gonna go up two rounds or it's
gonna be tied up or two matches
yeah yo he's definitely gonna go down
yeah
and that that's gonna add up oh nice
block
yep
[Music]
ftf with the patience punish oh nice
all right oh she's up
okay he's so ready for that time your
taunt means nothing to me it just
enrages me and watch makes me want to do
hot kicks
the law's in trouble one more hit now
he's in red though he has the red one he
can do it
[Music]
oh my god of all the choices there
brilliant
yeah i mean i wonder if he's been in
that situation before and he was like
you know what if i use this move it's
going to go around a lot of his options
fgl right now showing great match up
awareness one match a piece now but you
got to say mark bilal's gonna be um he's
gonna be hitting himself man he had so
many opportunities to close out those
rounds and he dropped most of them
and below he's going to pick a wall
stage he's definitely going to pick a
wild stage he's going to be like you
know what let me put you in some bad
situations i'm
upset that you stole those rounds away
from me
oh i can feel it i can feel it in my
loins it's going to happen i want to see
some more time jet uppers
yeah
fgl really is good at dealing with the
taunt pressure by the way that's what i
was going to say that's what i was gonna
say literally i was like you know how
many times has he hopkins in in between
to interrupt like the law has to start
to adapt to that
without hesitation either it's just like
as soon as bella found like an
opportunity to throw it out he was
already in the air it was it was yeah it
was brilliant i love seeing that
anyways we are going into the matchup um
that was much quicker than the first
time these guys are pissed he wants to
play let's go
yeah no messing about now man
we're not skipping turns we're going
straight in
no smoke breaks for you guys let's just
go into the match let's go
no pacing yep make it happen the full
moon you guys see it it's out
let's rock yeah
oh wow he back flipped out of there
oh he tried to catch some second hit
nice good patience here from fgl
fgl with a slight live lead here vlogs
gonna have to be careful
yep
hello trying to wait for opportunities
to to open up fgl if you're not giving
up many uh
of those
nice jab good challenge he's gonna get
the wall as well
okay careful
oh this time
and that's his answer to beating the hop
kick you know he had a feeling that he's
going to try and interrupt the taunt
again so he cancels it into three four
catch it gets the counter hit good
adaptation
that changes everything because at this
point what are you gonna do that
situation you're gonna have to stand
there and block and if you don't you're
gonna get counter hit
yeah
oh nice combo man
wow what an odds are back one match a
piece of around a piece
or you just don't get hit so you don't
be put in those situations just like
what happened fgl yeah now he's gonna
have to deal with it what's the okay
he tech roll again this man has no block
and he goes into the power crash once
more
yeah
fgl interrupting this aggression from
below stealing the momentum away from
him with those power crushes taking big
risks but it's working out for him
oh
what
interesting splat the follow up here oh
no go through the wheel kick once again
root of evil on the floor
oh no
he is so
old this is gonna hurt it's not gonna
kill
but it's gonna put him in a bad
situation here he's gonna have to deal
with either a low or standing three
what's going to happen
over three round four oh boy yo all
right
fdl in the lead
that's crazy
to stop the side step have you got one
more he's gonna do it there
oh that starts getting that's a horn
over extending again
oh no
the combo
this is an insane
insane sequence what are you going to do
how are you going to deal with it
no nice
so ballsy with that low
final round here third game
[Music]
at this point i could only watch
look if i'm on the pc back too
he's finally trying to find a way in fgl
the spacing immaculate catches him
starting stepping with the homie move
here we go pressure down jab throw bro
change the misery are you serious
oh my god you win the brian god
yes
the torch
what a way to end it that was so sick
can you imagine
let's do one of the hardest move
sequences in the game and bet it all on
this you have to be
a gangster you have to be so confident
in your skills
to be able to pull that off and yo he
did it to t the law you are crazy hey
man
maybe that was so impactful we don't
even have to play another game who knows
him into grand finals
on default he just moved to the grand
finals what a
call out there from below to finally go
for the taunton upper very if you guys
are not familiar with how hard that
actually is is one of the hardest things
to do in the game execution-wise and he
did it in the heat at the moment in the
final round with you know not much
health as well so crazy crazy composure
there from below to get that match and
now he has momentum here one match
needed mark to move into grand finals to
true to try and get his run back against
tom
man mg was doing so well too dealing
with the taunt series
but again we saw the adjustments
throughout the the set so far you know
he used three plus four he uses soccer
kick
and finally
saving it for the right timing he put
him into the perfect setup for that he
didn't have to do that he could have
just went for a mix-up but he wanted and
he knew he knew he was always tech
rolling
fto was always tech rolling there was no
situation where he did not tech roll he
was always tech rolling so it was only a
matter of time
yeah for sure he knew and you know the
thing is about about bilal people like
bilal and jimmy and these guys the
tonjappa is you know it's tough for me i
mean i can't do that i can be honest
with you it's not something i can do but
these guys are practicing so much just
become a second nation and you know
we've seen when jimmy when jimmy j used
to stream he used to end his streams by
doing six twenty uppers in a row on both
p1 and p2 and below does the same thing
these guys have the execution man it's
crazy i can't fathom it but they have it
man these are brian specialists and he's
2-1 up now he wants to get that run back
and if he does win this next match he
will guarantee himself to be at least
second place on the leaderboard for
south asia here for the second online
challenge 2021 so a very good position
for him to be in
yeah
and
i was just happy i saw that you know i'm
good i'm good for the rest of the day
you guys
everyone at home
i'm good you know you know
who cares about the grand finals i'm
happy i'll just talk i'll just [ __ ]
while we're while we're doing i'm not
even going to look at the screen i got
my shades on i'm good i'm good let me
show you
oh man yeah
i know i know it's crazy man thank you
so much for tuning in everybody man i
see that the viewership is going up
please share the stream and let everyone
know what's going on this top three
action here for toc south asia pakistan
versus pakistan here fgl the player that
no one knew about coming into this
tournament and he is um one match down
against bilal we're going back to the
infinite stage let's see if fgl can even
it and take it to a final match
we have this vicious cycle that's been
happening
no wall no wall
and if you know
if fgl wins again i wouldn't be
surprised if we went back to mashima
dojo
yeah the adaptations are being made here
now mark you see that you know the
disrespect on the taunt you know he's
dealt with it and other things you know
he starts to became more patient
i'm lucky the punishment as well
oh but some things never change
fdl is hella good he knows the exact
moments of that power that power is not
easy to use
yeah
okay
wow oh my god no way
how to make a statement without saying a
word that is
impressive you know he's had the right
lead on blocking that rage drive back to
back
her jabs are so much better just because
she could weave in and out and sideways
laterally oh my god hey man you gotta
like i was just complimenting him about
his use of that but again there's the
basketball oh my god
where are you going
the backhoe catch oh my gosh back home
plus frames yeah
just want to hear from that one oh my
god it ain't going to be the matter
catch
yep
that's a tough to deal with how do you
fight against that arsenal snake edges
i mean brian might have to pack his bags
we're going to the mashima dojo you want
to pack early
is it too late
is this karma is this payback for what
he did in the winner's side with the
snake hedges
look at this fgr
no beat down
there we go he's gonna get him he's
gonna test them yo
he is so good okay
already so ready there man three rounds
straight on the infinite once again
interrupting the taunt with the hot kick
ladies and lads moms and dads brother
sisters and friends were going to a
final match here for the losers finals
for south asia
man
we were almost theirs back
but this is gonna be decisive this is
the final match between these two
fairly good lilly bill all they're going
at it
uh man like i said i'm feeling good
already we're not even at grand finals
yet
make it happen i just make it happen
it's insane man i want to hear from you
guys at home i want to see spam of
emotes i want to see who you guys think
is going to take this because i can't
call it mark i know you can't call it
it's going to be too crazy like with
these guys this guy's been going back
and forth fgl we all love an underdog
story we all love you know at the new
player the new unknown person coming
coming through into the tournament and
and making a statement right we love
that imagine if he's actually able to go
into the grand finals and win the entire
thing it'd be insane but below on the
other hand he wants to run back man this
is the guy who wants to prove to himself
that he is
you know he's capable of winning these
tournaments you know the story he didn't
do so well in ukraine he was very upset
about it even months later he was
tweeting about how upset he was that he
didn't play to his potential now he is
one match away potentially from going
into the grand finals here for toc it's
all to play for we're going back to the
mishima dojo
okay
it's all come down to this
the final match between these two
players
that would uh that would be accessible
you know
um i probably need to i'll probably hang
out for like maybe two minutes but i'll
have to leave as well
all right a great start has fgo
yo he is looking good perfect
seven golden letters
spell it out baby perfect
oh
nice brilliance
oh the sidewall
is it necessary what are you going to do
how are you going to deal with it
you know after the opening round perfect
for fgl below almost getting a perfect
of his own very close
very dominant spacing in that round tied
up now one round apiece
spit all right
here we go two rounds to one fight
if fgl had any more uh meter left and
that was the time to use it absolutely
man it's last chance to loom now are we
going to see a final final round surely
but belong has all the momentum massive
light speed but fgm with a low parry
we're going to take it to the
corner oh
yo oh my god this is gonna hurt he might
be dead
he's dead he's not dead
oh nevermind
gonna eliminate fgl from the tekken
online challenge south asia master event
what a performance by fgl though out in
third place you gotta give it up guys no
one expected him to get this far and he
took a absolute beast on his way there
ursula wears a shot of dark prince and